All right.
A very, very big week for the David Pakman
show, the Joe Rogan appearance.
A lot of other stuff.
Um, so let's go to the phones and see what's
on people's minds at six one seven, eight,
three zero 47 50.
Um, let's start with our color from the two
oh five area code.
Who's calling today from two oh five.
Hey, good.
This is a, this is Corey.
Welcome back from California.
Thanks Corey.
What's going on?
So when I watched your interview, uh, I think
it was for the second time with are talking
about college and he pushed back about, uh,
the trades and emphasizing the trades more
and not, and not being for, you know, in particular,
fully subsidizing, let's say a university
based education.
One of the things that came to mind that I
was wanting to ask you for a while is why
not, uh, instead push for fully funding trades
maybe as a starting point, uh, and then to
expand, let's say towards, uh, subsidize or,
you know, fully subsidized university education.
Well, what would it be?
The reason to start with trades?
I mean, so you could start anywhere or you
could do both or you can do neither.
But what would be the reason to do trades?
First?
How would that help us eventually get to subsidizing
fully subsidizing, uh, State College?
Well, I think the thought would be, at least
in my mind, David would be that here you are
tackling what would be more in demand right
now.
So taking, taking Andrews, uh, concern, let's
say that that trades are heavily under represented
in the United Sates versus many of the other,
uh, European countries in particular focusing
on trades first as a way to, you know, not
just get a better representation but also,
uh, start to mitigate some of the incoming
problems around automation and how that might
affect, um, job opportunities in the United
States.
Listen, I don't know that the automation question
is going to be better handled by more trade
school versus more bachelor's degrees.
I think that really the fundamental question
around automation is going to be what portion
of the gains from automation go to the business
owners versus the employees.
And the way to think about it would be imagine
a company with a 100 employees.
Um, automation makes it so that, um, do you,
you only need 50 employees plus some machines
to get the same level of productivity.
There's basically like three possibilities
for how those gains were used in sort of like
a purely vulture capitalist system.
You would just lay off the 50 employees, you
would keep only 50, and the company gets all
of the gains of that technology.
In a socialist system, you would keep all
100 employees and the doubling of productivity
from the technology would allow every single
employee to just work half as much in like
a social democracy setting, we would say,
okay, some portion of the gains from that
technology can go to the business owner and
then some portion should be distributed among
the employees.
And where you set that line, like is it 5%
or 95% for the employees?
Depends sort of on your political philosophy.
I don't, that's a reality regardless.
I mean, that's gonna happen in both, uh, program,
uh, school, uh, jobs rather, that you need
a bachelor's degree for and jobs that you
would go to trade school for.
And I think it's just a broader economic question.
I don't know that we solve it more or less
by saying we're going to focus on funding
trade over bachelor's degrees.
Okay.
Thanks for the response.
All right, great to hear it from you, Corey.
I appreciate it very much.